what are you anyway an
if I had the idea for this movie about
seven years ago I wanted to do a movie
about imaginary friends called
ifs imaginary friend got
it this is a movie that John and I have
been talking about for years now
something that feels a bit like a live
action Pixar film and
action the movie is about a little girl
named be going through an experience in
her life that is troubling and as a
coping mechanism she starts to see every
single person's imaginary
friend hi all the ones that have been
left behind by the kids who have created
them and grown up and what does she do
with that superpower you could save all
of
us the man upstairs is a de facto
accomplice for bee and they strike up a
pretty unexpected
friendship chees
kind of a kid creates an invisible if in
the middle of it is an act of
imagination and John kazinski who not
only wrote the film directs the film but
he also absolutely enacts these
creatures for us all the time
[Music]
any the cast is insane I know for a fact
I will never get a better cast than this
and playing imaginary friends we have
Steve Carell Matt Damon John Stewart
Phoebe Waller Bridge Emily Blunt Maya
Rudolph Sam Rockwell LS Gosa Jr
Sebastian Maniscalco Chris Maloney
Richard Jenkins and
Aquafina put some pants on you're
freaking everyone
out imaginary friends are not just these
adorable creatures they are actually
time capsules for our hopes dreams
Ambitions it's fun it's
heartwarming it's a big family movie
with a little bit of everything it's
about that friend that's there for them
unconditionally and
always I wanted people to leave this
movie believing in something bigger and
believing in Something Beautiful will
actually get you through another day
because it's it's very real and it's
very
possible get it imaginary friend that's
enough sorry sorry it's just so exciting
that is too good okay we're done
for